vsauce kevin here with 100 pieces of
paper
and i'll teach you how to hire the right
plumber choose the best parking space
and even find the love of your life
by quitting each of these 100 slips of
paper has a number on it the numbers can
be anywhere from one
to a google which is one followed by 100
zeros
the game of google is to turn them over
one by one and stop when you think that
you've got the highest number
here's the important part your final
flipped paper
is your choice you can't like flip
five papers over and then retroactively
choose the
second paper because it had the highest
number no
no no no that's against the rules
so the trick to winning the game of
google is knowing when
to stop all right let's play paper
number one
one hundred thousand twenty eight okay
that's a pretty big number but it's not
even close to a google it it can't
possibly be
the highest number out of all of these
so let's flip
another 94 trillion 288 billion 381
million 109
276 that's huge
but it's far from a google so i should
probably keep going i
i think honestly i don't know
how am i supposed to choose the highest
numbered slip when i don't even know
what the numbers are
the lowest number could be seven or ten
thousand
the highest number could be well
anything
up to and including a google so the odds
of me
picking the highest number are what like
one percent or something
no the odds of me choosing correctly are
actually about one in three because i'm
going to employ
optimal stopping theory the branch of
mathematics that deals with
knowing when to quit that way you get
the highest reward
or the lowest cost the game of google
was invented in 1958
and it didn't take long for
mathematicians to figure out
an elegant approach the key is
e the number e
excuse me papers i gotta talk about some
e here
euler's number is an irrational number
that's roughly 2.71828
a mathematical constant that shows up in
exponential growth and even calculating
compound
interest e is one of the most important
numbers in mathematics
along with 0 1 pi and i
and it's a component of euler's identity
the gold standard of
mathematical beauty and to win the game
of google
we need to flip euler upside down
not like that like this the reciprocal
of euler's number
1 over e or 1 over 2.71828
or 0.367879 or
approximately 37 is the lowest our
probability of winning the game of
google will ever be
as long as we stick to the optimal
strategy we don't need to know the
numbers on the slips and
it doesn't matter if we're playing with
10 slips 100 slips or
642 duodecillion slips
we just need to answer one question
when exactly mathematically
do we start stopping okay
so i can just go through this solution
to the game of google
all right here we go
yeah looking good
yep no problems here and forget it
we're not gonna do that what we're gonna
do instead is that we're gonna use
e and basic optimal stopping theory to
find
a quick accurate point at which we need
to stop playing to maximize our chance
of winning let's solve the game of
google with just 10 slips of paper the
trick is to take a sample of numbers and
then decide to commit to the very next
number we pull
that's larger than any in the previous
sample
so with 10 slips total do we decide to
take the highest number
after what the third the fifth
it can't be too late in the game because
if we wait until
like slip nine we'll likely have already
revealed
and passed over our biggest number let's
not guess
let's get oily
if we divide our number of slips 10 by e
we get 3.67889
by rounding up to the next integer we
can stop collecting
our sample on the fourth slip
then we'll keep choosing slips and stop
when we find one that's higher than any
of those first
four and there's around a one over e
chance that
we'll be right this works for 10
100 or 3781 slips
because that's just 3781 divided by
e so 1 1390.95
we'd choose until we pulled a number
higher than any in the 1391st
slip we'll be exactly right about a
third of the time
and when we aren't we'd still be really
close
look i'll mix these up and i'll play a
totally random game using this strategy
and we'll just see what happens
so there's my sample of four slips and
now we'll just choose the next number
that's bigger than these four
alright my choice is number six let's
see if that's the highest number here
oops so the strategy didn't work
six wasn't the highest number it was
actually slip number nine
a one out of three success rate of this
strategy might not sound
impressive you're still gonna lose about
two out of every three times
but imagine how low your success rate
would be if you had no system to help
you decide and as the number of slips in
the game of google becomes
larger the likelihood that your
uninformed guess is actually right
trends towards zero thirty something
percent is a lot better than say
point zero zero three percent
as humans don't calculate probabilities
with euler's number
10 times a day but our brain does
seem to have a general heuristic a
series of mental shortcuts and basic
rules
that helps us decide when to stop
researchers at the laboratory of
neuropsychology at the national
institute of mental health
ran fmri scans on brains that were
trying to decide whether to keep
searching for the best
choice or commit to the current option
and they found
that several parts of the brain light up
when faced
with an optimal stopping problem
euler's number and optimal stopping
theory is how in a sea of possibilities
you decide
this is the best parking spot that i'm
gonna find
or this is the house that i'm gonna buy
or this is the youtube video that
i'm gonna watch without even realizing
it you played the game of google in your
brain to watch
this video about the game of google
you didn't scroll through every single
video on youtube and go back to
determine
that this was the one to click on you
scan some options
clicked me and here we are
you're johannes kepler and i'm
bachelorette number five in 1611 kepler
interviewed 11 women
in the hopes of finding a wife he passed
on
11 women kepler was left alone
he rejected all of his options and
thought he'd missed his chance luckily
he went back to bachelorette number five
she said yes and they lived happily ever
after
kepler found the love of his life but he
did it the hard way
all he needed to do was divide eleven by
e to get a value around four
and then taken the very next option
better than those
which would have been bachelorette
number five
the love of his life hidden in
plain math all along
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
you